so there's a new Wikipedia article for
the crisis happening in the Red Sea
let's look at the map this is the Red
Sea it's where tens of thousands of
merchant ships travel through to keep
our global economy running lately rebels
in Yemen have been firing missiles and
drones at these cargo ships you can see
all of these attacks here right at this
choke point where Yemen and jibuti come
together so far the rebels have hit like
10 of these cargo ships and they say
they're doing it to punish Israel and
its backers for this war that's
happening in Gaza this is a nightmare
for shipping companies who are now
having to reroute their ships to much
longer routes and it's causing all these
price issues and it's not good this
Waterway is very critical to the global
economy so the US and UK and other
countries are sending in their navies
intercepting these attacks and trying to
stabilize this vital Waterway this
Waterway affects all of us because we
are all attached to the global economy
whether we like it or not so I'm going
to keep an eye on this if you want to
better understand global politics follow
along for more